Coffee on a Tuesday and block 16.
I should start by saying I'm more of an
atheist than it is.
In other words,
my view is not just that there is no
reason to believe that there is a deity
and that all the arguments that there is
one have long since been exploded by
philosophers,
astronomers,
scientists,
physicists,
biologists and so forth.
Um,
mainly by philosophers,
the,
my opinion,
um,
but that it's a good thing that that's
not okay.
How do we describe Christopher Hitchens
as a writer,
journalist,
teacher,
political commentator,
contrarion atheists,
extremely adept debater as a champion of
truth,
democracy,
whiskey,
and a piece of advice his mother gave
him when he was just a young boy,
that the only unforgivable sin is to be
born.
Yvonne's advice was never forgot.
It became one of the most successful at
penetrating thinkers of his time.
Publishing several books,
tearing down sacred cows from Mother
Teresa.
Fanatical Albanian
dwarf lying.
Thieving of Bill Clinton.
No,
I think he is even by,
even by the most relaxed standard,
an unusually hollow and empty and cold
individually and completely ruthless.
Henry Kissinger,
criminal is Henry [inaudible].
Job description on has been since you
first caught Richard Nixon's.
Yeah,
I had.
The one and only got the Christian
answer is,
of course you have freewill.
The boss insists upon it.
You lionized Jefferson,
Orwell,
Thomas Paine.
He wrote columns for Vanity Fair,
slate magazine,
the Atlantic.
He was a prolific and viber and inhaler
two things which no doubt shortened his
life in the end,
but he was too smart not to know that
you get out of alcohol,
what you put into it,
and as he was a scotch man like me and a
Johnny Walker man like me,
I can only say simply everything in
moderation.
Take two.
And as he was a scotch man like me and a
Johnny Walker man like me,
I can only say three.
Take for everything in moderation.
Takes Breakfast of champions.
League is work for yourself.
Agree with him or done.
My Point is not to vindicate his.
To me.
Christopher hitchens represents
something.
The world is always in short supply of
men and women of letters,
intellectual,
one apologetic for being so sometime in
the last couple of centuries,
intellectuals lost their credit and the
western world and just when they were
doing so good in the enlightenment in
our time,
the word intellectual has come to be
synonymous with pretend anti
intellectualism isn't old and repetitive
story.
It made itself a home in Mussolini's,
Italy,
Stalin's Russia,
Hitler's Germany,
where you can trace it back in time
through religion all the way to the
death of socrates or you can move
forward in time to the populist.
Politicians like George W,
but I like to mountain bike.
I liked country music on my ipod
strategy.
We're intellectuals are pitted against
the uncorrupt salt of the earth.
Good to have a beer with folk like this.
Anti intellectual wisdom is troubling in
all its manifestations,
but maybe nowhere more so than in youth
court.
They
are impressionable and they have the
cash.
They are corporate America's $150
million dollar dream.
The idea here is that the advertising
industry has transformed the language
thought and actions of teenagers into
commodities.
In order to sell them popularity,
creating a generation who was completely
uninterested in maturing to adult,
but take this how you want.
There is certainly a good point here,
but what I saw in myself and others as a
young teenager was that being an idiot
is ease.
It's amazing when you're an idiot.
Everything that comes out of your mouth
is idiotic with no work at all,
but when you want to be intelligent,
everything you say requires a little
work,
a little bit of thought and effort to
compose yourself,
so it's not to be inane or contradictory
or redundant,
doesn't mean that intellectuals can't be
silly.
It doesn't mean that we can't turn our
brains off every once in a while.
We all need them.
Well being an intellectual,
no matter how you slice it is hard.
It takes introspection and time and a
willingness to be critical of yourself
and it never stops being hard.
It gets harder.
The reward is that hard work becomes the
reward.
Learning becomes a commodity as bright
and infinitely renewable as the sun.
Everyone can and should be an
intellectual,
whether you're a doctor or a plumber or
a president or a germ.
All it takes is putting yourself on the
record.
It takes writing something and
submitting it to the public for if
you're a painter,
lawyer,
filmmaker,
dancer,
that's great,
but still right,
musician,
engineer,
diplomat,
accountant.
Fantastic.
What still words or the units of thought
and if you listen to anything I say,
let it be this.
We learn by saying,
not think ideas are like clouds.
You can't hold onto when we compose a
sentence,
we make the idea of solid.
Then we can put it in our pockets and
take it with us.
What do you think it takes to lead a
good life?
For me,
I'm irony.
I'm literature as the source of
reflection on moral and ethical and
human topics.
I'm laughing at the misfortunes of
others that gets me through it all.
Um,
I love,
uh,
and some of the things that go with,
um,
the possibility of passing on your genes
to children,
the,
any kind of immortality or whatever.
And did I mention this already?
Laughing at the misfortune of others.
And it will be improved,
right?
I'm being vindicated in arguments that
other people wish they hadn't had with
you.
They have to say,
okay,
I was Roman.
You are right.